lo que quiero hacer aquí en primer lugar
es mostrarles cómo resolvería yo este
problema de restar 68 menos 42 y que me
parece es la manera más típica es
escribir primero el número al que se le
va a restar arriba 68 y abajo el número
que restar hemos del de arriba en este
caso 42 menos 42 y en lo que debemos
pensar y hay que asegurarse de hacerlo
es alinear los números de manera que las
unidades queden con las unidades en la
misma columna las escenas con las
decenas de las centenas con las centenas
etcétera una vez que nos aseguramos de
esto vamos a pasar directamente a las
unidades 8 es menor que 2 por lo que
podemos hacer esta resta 8 menos 2 es
igual a 6 y lo ponemos aquí justo
abajito en esta columna de manera que
coincida con las unidades más adelante
les voy a explicar por qué esto funciona
ahora pasamos a las decenas ese 6 por la
posición en la que está en realidad nos
representa unos 60 este 4 nos representa
un 40 porque están las escenas
r aquí 60 menos 46 46 menos cuatro es
igual a 2 nos queda aquí 26 aunque en
realidad este 2 es un 20 por la posición
en la que está y hasta aquí la operación
está terminada
de hecho los invito a que revisen que
esto está bien hecho realizando las
siguientes operaciones a 68 restarle 26
y verán que como resultado obtienen un
42 o sumen 42 más 26
y les va a dar 68 los invito a que hagan
esto por su cuenta para que verifiquen
que esta resta se realizó correctamente
ahora quiero explicarles por qué
funciona este método a mí me gusta
visualizar esto como tener 60 más ocho
que 68 es lo mismo y al restar 42 aquí
pongo menos 40 menos 2 es exactamente lo
mismo estoy restando en 42 sólo que
estoy separando o desarrollando la
anotación dejando las unidades
expresamente en un lado las decenas en
otro lado y así sucesivamente de manera
que lo vemos como dos problemas
separados así 8 menos 26
60 menos 40 me va a dar 20 si es 120 6
me va a dar 26 y es exactamente el mismo
resultado que obtuvimos acá en las que
dibuje un cero medio feito ahí están y
con esto hemos terminado